I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your questions are you prepared
to call Ham a terror group is it
possible to have a rational I've asked
you two questions should a m stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on peor sensed live from New
York City alien President Biden tries to
jump start his re-election campaign as
the polls show the Democrats are
sleepwalking into potential electoral
disaster if they really think Trump's a
democracy wrecking demagogue why don't
they have a plan to beat him that may
work we'll debate that and I'll talk to
the only selected Democrat who's
challenging the
president and the world's biggest
Aviation Authority says it's actively
recruiting more people with mental
health problems a victory for inclusion
or plain stupid Matt W returns to
uncensored to discuss that and
[Music]
more live from New York this is Pier
Morgan
uncensored good evening from New York
welcome to PE Morgan uncensored whether
we monarchist Brits like to admit it or
not the president of the United States
is the single most important person in
the world commanding the world's mest
military and holding the pur strings of
its biggest economy the president could
end Israel's war in Gaza with a phone
call or decide if Ukraine gets the
backing it needs to beat Putin at least
that's the general idea but the current
commander-in-chief is 81 seemingly going
on 181 a lifetime of distinguished
Public Service as a pragmatic politician
and in my view a thoroughly decent human
being President Biden looks increasingly
unfit for service and with the president
invisible decline his re-election
campaign is well transitioning you might
say it's pronouns are changing before
our very eyes the two most important
women in President Biden's life have
been sent out to jump start the 2024
race wildly unpopular VP car Harris said
this we've got 10 months to go until the
election C MH and increasingly and
you've seen it even just this week um we
are all starting to narrow in on what
this election will mean yeah and it's
going to be the choice
between what is about respecting our
democracy what is about competence
versus
chaos well the vice president is Right
competence is crucially important but
her own boss has trouble getting up the
stairs and C seem to find a way off a
stage Is frequent verb and physical
stumbles are the subject of both comedy
and concern most people responded with
laughter and derision for example when
first lady Jill Biden said this about
him I see Joe every day I see him out
you know traveling around this country I
see his Vigor I see his energy to those
who say I can't vote for Joe Biden he's
too old what do you say I say his age is
an
asset H energy and vigor not quite what
I'm seeing you can make a plausible case
for the wise old Statesman with a firm
hand on the tiller but campaigning on
Biden's Vigor May well FasTrack Donald
Trump who does have a lot of vigor to
the White House Now 77 Trump's no spring
chicken himself but with his diet
defying Swagger and Showmanship most
people on his side seem to be believing
it when he says things like this I feel
like I'm about 35 years old I actually
feel better now than I did 30 years ago
tell me is that crazy I feel better now
and I think cognitively I'm better than
I was 20 years ago I don't know
why that is a slightly more debatable
subject Mr Trump but a whopping 77% of
Americans both Republican and Democrats
believe that Biden is simply too old to
run the country almost 70% think he's
mismanaged the crisis at the southern
border just 133% say they're financially
better off on his watch at this stage of
his term he's the least popular US
president in recorded history and this
stuff matters us politics is Inc almost
hysterically polarized to the rest of us
outside America but most voters are in
fact ready to be persuaded white
working-class voters ditched the
Democrats to propel Trump to office in
2016 now more and more Hispanic and
black voters a shifting Republican too
Biden says he's the only man who's ever
beaten Trump and that's true but right
now he may be the only one who can lose
to Trump in November well I'm joined by
my Super PAC here in the studio New York
co-host of The Breakfast Club
Charlamagne the god host of the Rubin
report Dave Rubin and a Democrat
strategist and Fox News contributor
Jessica tof who I could hear her lips
pursing as I read that
monologue I could feel them puring
appreciate though I saw you tempered it
a bit whoever put it in theor was
harsher than you were I could feel the
personing I was raining back in real
time um let me start with you Jessica
because I like Joe Biden personally I
think he's got a lot of very admirable
qualities as a human being and his own
story you know the fact he lost his wife
and a baby when he was just a senator he
then lost another son anyone that can do
that and still do the job he's doing
will always have my admiration but there
is no doubt he is in real trouble here
is there any doubt I mean can you paint
a picture that isn't as Grim as the one
I painted oh I definitely can do that
and I've been preparing for three and a
half minutes chance I I'm not going to
start by denying that the age factor is
massive in all of this and I think that
people's concerns as well about KLA
Harris and her Readiness to take over
informs that if there was a hugely
popular vice president kind of waiting
in the wings I think things might feel a
bit different for people but 81 is 81
there are some 81 year olds we all watch
Warren Buffett right MC jagu is 80 yes
nearly 81 he would have a different kind
of agenda for the country but yes he
does might be quite a popular one yeah
that would be pretty I wouldn't hate
it but there is a problem going on right
now with media coverage of the Biden
presidency and there are problems with
the Biden campaign what are the problems
so I'll start with media coverage
everybody knows now that you want to
print stories that get clicks and
negative stories are the ones that do
with it even people who are huge
supporters of the president focus on all
the polls that are negative most people
wouldn't know that if you went to the
real clear politics homepage and clicked
on polls the average has Joe Biden down
just one percentage point to Trump you
would think that he was getting trounced
youd look at swing state polls and you'd
see that in a lot of the Swing States
like Pennsylvania for instance which is
going to be a huge deal he's up
massively we only talked about the fact
that he was down in one Michigan poll
last week in terms of the economic news
The Wall Street Journal our very own
Wall Street Journal here at News Corp um
had a hugely optimistic set of
editorials out there 62% of Americans
think the next year so 2024 election
year is going to be better for them when
are they going to go and vote in
November that's a lot of time for this
economic recovery to really settle in
for people but no one wants to talk
about that it's not popular it's not
good clickbait the second part about the
campaign and this is where I think the
Obama folks who have been perhaps too
publicly critical I think of the Biden
campaign their ground game is not
visible to folks they don't feel like
they're there in Nevada in Arizona in
Georgia in these states that we
desperately need to win and they are
working on that and I think that the
president himself needs to be more
visible I if if I was working in the
white house I would have him out there
all the time I understand you might be
risking a stumble I wouldn't I do what
they did with him last time I keep him
keep him in a dungeon I mean look yeah
here's the thing I think the problem
it's not excuse me it's not his age I
think that Joe Biden's problem is the
clear senility yeah that's going with
his age like I said I Met m Jagger last
summer absolutely bursting with the vi
and vigor that Jill wants us to believe
she sees in go look Piers do any of us
sitting at this table or anyone watching
this think that he could run one shift
at McDonald's and I don't mean that as a
shot for someone that works at
McDonald's there cognitively but but I
don't think he could I think a lot of
senior citizens could because I don't
think it's an age thing I agree with you
it's it's a cognitive D Collins at the
emies stole the show she's 90 years old
good friend of mine she looks about 50
and she has the mental acuity of a 50y
old she has vim and vigor so I know Jill
Biden is right to say it's about Vim
andg figure but her husband doesn't
exude it well look let's put it this way
you opened by saying something about
ailing Joe Biden and I thought oh I
haven't looked at my phone in 20 minutes
did something else it's a general aing
it's ailing yes we all know it the
wandering off when they put get him off
the plane and the confusion he literally
on camera last what was it two years ago
said let's go let's go Brandon like
something is not right we all know it
and I would say respectfully in terms of
the polls and everything people don't
vote on what really matters we vote on
what we can feel right and I think
because of that people are going Donald
Trump he seems back there's energy there
and there's just no energy with Biden
and nobody nobody likes Kamala that's
but Trump has lost every election except
2016 I mean loser and yeah right right
to the point the Democrats decided to
finish him off with 91 criminal charges
and thought this will do him he's down
he's wounded and and he's had the
complete oppos opposite effect he has
used that to play the Marty the victim
it has fueled a resurgent trump and you
cannot deny I mean I've seen people try
to downplay what happened to Iowa but if
that had been Joe Biden who' done that
at Iowa you'd be saying this is
unbelievable it's a landslide it's
amazing he's killing them right Trump is
back and I think will definitely be the
nominee regard unless there some
extraordinary Twist of events he's
exuding the air of someone on a mission
he's got vim and vigor and whether you
love him or hate him it's equal doses
with Trump you got to say Trump V Biden
in November I could see Trump winning
that is there anything about Iowa that
makes you say maybe uh Republicans
should pivot and go to somebody like a
Nikki Haley maybe like when you see that
she picks up you know a lot of Democrats
a lot of Independents you think that
they're doing themselves a disservice by
maybe not getting behind her because you
know the GOP is going to fall in line
and she's somebody who seems like they
can pick up votes from from both sides
yeah I mean but you yourself you made
news by talking about the vi and vigor
Claim by Joe Biden didn't you I mean
you're yeah I don't see the V not
whatever V Vigor whatever yeah and I had
I had a great time on your breakfast
club show uh yesterday and it was it was
really enlightening conversation we had
but you know it's not that I like you
said to you are you telling people to
vote Trump no it's not for me to tell
people how to vote in this country and
I've been very critical of trump in the
last since certainly over all the whole
the stolen election nonsense the January
6th thing I wasn't buying into any of
that and in a way I felt that was
disqualifying but we are we are it
didn't disqualify him he could actually
go to prison and still be president of
the United States constitutionally so
we're into completely Uncharted
Territory all I do feel is the more the
Democrats have tried to kill him off
particularly with all these criminal
charges the more that even Republicans
that don't like him have gone you know
what it is a Witch Hunt the Liberals are
trying to nail this guy is one of us
we're going to back him and so it's been
self-defeating MH a bit like the Russian
collusion thing yeah I I agree with that
and um I think the interesting thing is
if you're going to use language like you
know this is going to be the end of
democracy as we know it then there needs
to be a sense of urgency like you said
when is the ground game going to start
why is the ground game just start now if
it's going to be you know the end of
democracy and I think that's what scares
people too if if if we see the the clear
and to me anyway the clear and present
danger that could be a second Trump
presidency is the Biden Harris ticket a
winnable ticket I'm a person who voted
for Joe Biden in 2020 so I don't think
it's anything wrong with asking that
question do you think it's a winnable
ticket I don't know when I look at the
polls I don't think so you know I think
that a 60 plus year old no incumbent
president with this poll rating that
Biden's currently at in the low 30s has
ever been reelected yeah I don't I don't
I mean yeah when I look at it I don't
think so me you never know you can you
can say it's 50/50 but I think a 60 plus
year old Joe Biden you know with the
things he's done as far as like you know
the infrastructure Bill even even the
student loan forgiveness you know the
way the economy is now I think a 60
something year old Joe Biden Jo you he
also said to you on your show which
again made headlines make a lot of
headlines sure I'm jealous um but he
said if you're black and you don't vote
for me you're not black I me it it's a
joke but what did you think when he said
that was that was that a sense of
entitlement a bit of arrogance about the
African-American vote I think that you
know he has too many uh black friends
around him and they made him feel
comfortable enough to make that joke I
feel like he probably had a bunch of
black people around him who have said
that exact language cuz when they say
that they're saying that hey if you vote
for Trump you're literally voting you
know against your own interest as a
black person and I think he's heard that
a bunch of times so he thought that that
would been a nice little let me ask you
a specific thing to about this right so
Trump this is where I have a problem
with Trump every time I sort of you know
I he makes me laugh right he just does
when he said that thing on the eve of
Iowa that even if it kills you come out
and
votee world yeah but watching watching
poac liberals lose their mind when he
does that stuff makes me chuckle right I
I've seen myself as pretty down the
middle but I just I think he's funny and
he's and he can make people laugh but
when he says this I don't laugh right he
said the president of the United States
is on Truth social yesterday president
of United States must have full immunity
without which it would be impossible for
him her to properly function any mistake
even if well intended will be met with
almost certain indictment by the
opposing party at termen for even events
that cross the line must fall under
total immunity I so I so I tweeted so if
President Biden orders the immediate
assassination of you Donald Trump that's
okay is it that's covered what you're
explaining is the true magic of Donald
Trump whether you love his policies or
not because on one hand you're going
well there are certain lines when he
pokes fun at the but he means this no no
so but so your line now is he put it in
quotes crosses the line I can tell I can
tell when I can tell when he's laughing
and joking So You Think You think when
he says cross the line what he meant was
I can take out Joe Biden no that was me
suggesting that that's where you take
the argument but what do you think he
means I think what he me
no no I think he's actually as always
with Trump his self-interest he wants to
basically make sure he can't jack Smith
go home yeah that's what he means and
he's and if the corollary is my
political opponent could kill someone he
then wants to talk about 2016 when we
all ran around and said you know he
could shoot someone in the middle of
Fifth Avenue and and his supporters
wouldn't care by this new criteria he
could do that and get away with it right
well I think there are some legal
questions as per what a president is
allowed to get away with and not be
prosecuted after but I'm pretty sure
murder is not one of them like outright
murder don't know that he would like it
to be he would like anything that
crosses the line to fall under total
immunity the man has open agulation for
XI Jin for Kim Jong-un he he's a wannabe
dictator and I don't you know I've been
at Fox News my entire media career I do
not fancy myself an msmc type person who
wants to lose their mind about those
things but that is very serious to have
someone who was the leader of the Free
World and is running to be it again to
believe that these people who are athma
to democracy are doing it right what
does you feel and also to though we're
acting like you know it's not just
rhetoric yes he said he want to be a
dictator for a day yes he said you know
he should be immune from killing you
know immune from killing his political
Rivals but he also attempted a CP with
his country guys right like why are we
acting like that did not happen why we
keep acting like January 6 did not
happen I mean it didn't happen I mean
what that a bunch of people showed up
with no plans no weapons I mean I'm not
defending the people that actually broke
windows or anything else but there was
no coup there was no cool this country I
got eyes and ears I'm not a political
expert was there a plan did anyone have
a piece of paper that said proud boys
had a plan and they were invited into
the White House there were people with
zip ties that's not a casual thing that
you walk around with I'm not diin valid
they were talking about hanging the
Thousand there were only aund bad ones
let's say that doesn't mean that it
wasn't an attempted coup fermented by
the president of the United States of
America I mean does anyone honestly
think that Donald Trump thought that the
next day he would be president you know
post transition potential trans B does
which is why he finally had to go there
are people I mean what was so powerful
about the January 6 committee and what
they were able to put together is the
fact that they used almost exclusively
Republican testimony people who had
worked for him I mean look at the text
messages from his own son to Mark
Meadows or what ianka had to be honest
about when she testified or Jared
Kushner or Cassidy Hutchinson who
they're going after now I mean he made a
mockery of our system and frankly I mean
it speaks to the strength of our
institutions and the backbone of Mike
Pence for that eight hours that he was
able to I thought it was a pretty I got
to say it was a pretty terrifying spect
I'm sure watching it abroad you thought
the hell is going on I remember emailing
one of his team and saying what you've
got to get him out there and call this
thing off and he didn't for a long
period of time while this Mayhem was
erupting you can dress it anywh you like
you can spin it anywh you're to
thousands of people whipped up into a
mindset of we have to stop this
Democratic action happening stormed into
the epicenter of American politics and
they tried to take control and in their
eyes stop democracy happening now the LI
the liberal response by the way which is
to Classic liberal resp which is
completely halfast which is to say right
let's take him off the ballot now in
loads of different states is obviously
stupid that is the you don't try and
stop a guy you think has tried to thwart
democracy by thwarting democracy can I
tell say two things one Charlamagne
brought up a point that I wanted to add
on to that's really important about the
vien Vigor right so Donald Trump I don't
think that he's going to trip and fall
and die tomorrow but when people do see
him he's talking absolute rubbish he's
he's done that for 50 years I mean come
but people I I agree I and I didn't even
like his shows when it was on regular TV
but my
point come on the 2008 Celebrity
Apprentice was the stuff of
Masterpiece but the kind of
communication that he's putting out
there he's even in the last 48 hours we
went from Iowa I was there I was on air
and I said this is a big accomplishment
for him he's being consilio how long
will it last then we got to immigrants
are poisoning the blood of americ
then defaming a woman who he's been
charged they found him guilty of
sexually assaulting her he continues
with that he talking about how magnets
work in water you know using ID to buy a
loaf of bread it's not like people who
are at home are saying this guy got it
together and this guy doesn't you know
what you know what we're going to come
back I'm going to talk after the break
to De Phillips and keep you guys here to
react to that but I also want to talk
about what Jamie Diamond said which I
thought was really interesting when he
said that if you call everyone is a Maga
supporter a supporter of trump if you
call them a bunch of crazies then you
are completely missing the point why
most of them actually want to vote for
Trump which is economy foreign policy uh
the Border all these things which he was
strong on last time he said that's why
they want him back because they feel
they've been let down on that by Biden
we'll talk about that after the break uh
stay with me uncensored next more from
my New York super back I'll be joined by
the Democratic presidential candidate
who wants Joe Biden to stand aside he's
Minnesota con Congressman Dean Phillips
and he'll be here live in a couple of
[Music]
minutes we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about supp today we do it all sunak
sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an Al in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fast
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Carin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for AIT if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan should
have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC Mouse man
mcmouse man mous he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should Hass stay
in power and are there a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that welcome back to p on sensor live
from New York City Democrats are
privately fretting about President
Biden's disastrous polling in the race
for the White House very few of them are
prepared to say it out loud only one
elected Democrat has been bold enough to
run against the incumbent president and
US Representative Dean Phillips is that
man and joins me now Mr Phillips thank
you for joining me I guess the first
question for the global audience is who
are you and why do you want to be
president who am I and why do I want to
be president well I'll tell you my quick
story I lost my father in the Vietnam
War he was a soldier who served his
country and gave his life to our country
uh I got very lucky 3 years later my mom
remarried I was adopted into a
remarkable family uh one of many
blessings uh including business
philanthropy my grandmother was the
advice columnist Dear Abby entered our
family business built badier vodka then
sold that built talente gelato the ice
cream brand and peers I woke up the
morning after the 2016 election I found
my youngest daughter in her bedroom in
tears and I recognized life has changed
in America and around the world I
promised them my two daughters I would
do something I ran for congress I
flipped a district that that had not
elected a Democrat since 1958 and I beat
an incumbent by who had won by 14 points
I beat him by 12 and I got to the US
Congress in 2019 and found an
unmitigated dysfunctional disaster that
is easily fixed with good leadership
peers and you ask why I'm running for
president well the overwhelming
exhausted majority of Americans center
right center left Americans Common Sense
people are tired of this they want to
turn the page from both Trump and Biden
and I tell you I tried to get the
president to pass the torch I called
other candidates who are better known
than me none of them would do it so I
thought it was time for courage my
father gave his life to this country and
I entered the race because if not now
when and if not me who and I got to tell
you pierce it is a joyful journey and
Americans are not as divided as anger
tainment would have us believe and I'm
going to make change in a common sense
decent way that engages Democrats and
Republicans and moves Beyond dangerous
nonsense well everything you say makes
perfect sense except this Joe Biden if
he doesn't Stand Down will be the
nominee now twice in post second world
war history there has been an incumbent
Democrat president who has done that you
know Lyndon Johnson did it and there was
another president who did it um they
stood down and didn't go forward but if
Joe Biden doesn't do that voluntarily
you have no way
in well appears I don't I don't I don't
buy into that I'll tell you I've spent
my life my professional life disrupting
businesses and categories trying to
disrupt the US Congress that is in
desperate need of it and that's why I'm
doing this again as long as American
voters actually get out and vote in the
primary anything is possible Joe Biden's
not a bad man he's a good man but he's
81 years old he's facing the lowest
approval numbers in American
presidential history every poll he's
losing including the Battleground States
and even you know Charlemagne the God
who was just on with you moments ago and
I was on The Breakfast Club just about a
week ago uh he's speaking the truth too
saying the quiet part out loud he's not
electable so Democrats will have a
choice Pier sometime soon to either go
and coordinate a candidate who is going
to lose or go with hope and optimism and
a brighter future uh with a candidate me
who's 54 years old and able willing
competent and ready to combine the very
best of center right center left
thinking in America and stop the
nonsense and win that's the choice of
American voters and we got to practice
democracy not just talk about it all
right look you haven't got much time
give me three things you would do if you
were president tomorrow top priorities
oh let me start with let me St let me
talk about executive leadership I will
have a bipartisan cabinet of the best
and brightest Americans Democrats and
Republicans I will have a youth cabinet
I will employ zerob based budgeting I
will actually manage our federal
government in a fiscally responsible
manner uh I will address the southern
border which is an unmitigated mess and
disaster inhumane horrible for our
economy and our International reputation
and we have must reform our Asylum
policies and then I will do what is most
important for Americans right now costs
and Chaos are out of control life is
unaffordable 60% of Americans living
paycheck to paycheck 40% cannot afford a
$400 emergency we've got to attack
affordability and we've got to end the
chaos not just in the United States but
all around the world end the wars invest
in peace and bring this country together
and do our best to bring this world
together before it's too late piers and
that's going to take all of us and by
the way as some have noted Jamie Diamond
about Biden condemning all Trump
supporters I welcome and invite Trump
supporters I love everybody as long as
you are people of principle and decency
and want to work together peers we got
to change this nonsense the two parties
are the problem and I'm running for
change and I don't mind that disruption
because I think most people want it well
it's good of you to uh join me Mr
Phillips I would personally say you
probably have two hopes of succeeding no
hope and Bob Hope but I do admire the
aspiration and I actually like the cut
of your jib as well so you never know in
politics right hey you never know you
got to get give it a shot and by the way
mark my words watch here in New
Hampshire on January 23rd Just 4 days
from now you might be
surprised I I look forward to it I would
love to be surprised Dean Philips thank
you very much and D for joining me
Charlamagne you got what an optimist you
are you know what I am I'm I'm an
optimist tinge with being a realist
right you got to be real about this I
don't think Joe Biden has shown any
indication of wanting to stand down at
all unless he voluntarily does that is
persuaded to he is going to be the
nominee right and for someone like you
um you've become with your show various
shows but The Breakfast Club in
particular has this extraordinary number
of young black people who tune in
religiously to listen to it to watch it
and to think what do they want what do
they want from their president I mean
they got two elderly white guys right
running for president this is not an
Obama 20089 scenario what do they want
to happen here well when you talk about
it in those terms number one they want
both of them to step out the way they
want the GOP to move away from Trump
they want you know Democrats to move
away from Biden but I don't care who you
talk to most folks you speak to want
upward Mobility like it's all about
money like that's the conversation that
they should be having when they're
having conversations about you know
creating jobs when they're having
conversations about the economy being
better that's great but is it trickling
down to the least of us you know is it
trickling down to the hood is it
trickling down to the rural areas rural
areas like where I'm from in mon Corner
South Carolina if those people aren't
feeling the relief then you know they
feel like you know what you're doing is
is necessarily what does you feel about
Jamie Diamond who says that you know if
you if you just ridicule and mock the
mager crowd the the really hardcore
Trump supporters it's wrong that you
should respect all Americans right
they're entitled their opinion entitled
to vote for who they want to vote for I
mean I thought he had a point he also
had a point that if you just over
demonize Trump I think I said on on your
show I met Chris Rock after the 2016
election the next day and he said if
someone's murdered eight people don't go
around saying he's murdered nine about
Trump in other words you just exaggerate
how bad he is it people are going to
find out see that was 2016 I think in
2024 like we kind of see what a trump
presidency is is like and how bad it
could potentially be and what are you
most worried about with him uh I'm
worried about you know uh the threat to
democracy seriously because when you
hear a guy say hey we should get rid of
the constitution in order to overturn
the results of election like when you
hear a guy say you hear his lawyers in
court say well he never agreed to uh
support the Constitution it's like whoa
I don't care if you're Democrat
Republican black white gay straight if
you're an American citizen you cannot
have a leader of a free world who does
not respect the Constitution Dave you
can't have someone who doesn't respect
the Constitution well first off the
beauty of America and our system and the
Constitution and the rest of our
founding documents is that they work and
we've separated Powers enough so that
guys like Donald Trump potentially if he
wanted to be dictator it's not that you
just flip a switch and suddenly you're
dictator why not using the 14 well hold
on a second I would also say that if you
look at the actual reality of Trump's
presidency preco the economy was booming
we had the Abraham accord's lowest
all-time black unemployment lowest
all-time Latino unemployment and you may
remember at the State of the Union when
he mentioned that and AOC and the rest
of the Congressional Black Talk has sat
there like this I thought they would
have been for low black unemployment so
Trump has done a lot of things right and
I'm saying this as somebody that wasn't
even supporting him three days ago I
mean I'm a disantis guy I moved to
Florida because Jamie Diamond to be to
be clear he's not a big Trump suppor
he's locked horns with Trump a few times
he's donated to the Democrats right it's
not and Trump has rubbished him in
public about doing business in China so
it's not like he's a DieHard Trumper
himself he just made the point which I
think is right which is if you just
abuse everyone that votes for him you
are basically committing an act of self
harm what I would recommend anyone do as
this election keeps going is as the rall
start again and I did not vote for Trump
in 2016 I did vote for him the first
time but one of the uh the second time
and one of the reasons that I ended up
doing it was one day in La I happened to
drive by a rally and I was like you know
what let me just go in there and see
what's going on and there were black
people and there were Latinos and gays
for Trump and it was a joyfest it was a
party American flags everywhere it
wasn't some coales idea of let's take
out democracy or take out the marxists
or anything else it was basically kind
of like an Fu to the system and and then
just this mix of politics I mean that's
the Jessica were you with this party
he's talking about
it was right I wasn't invited there were
gays blacks Latinos but no liberals what
did you think what did you think were an
awful lot of yeah there were four Bernie
Sanders voters who probably didn't turn
up what did you think of Jamie Diamond's
comen because they were I think Jamie
Diamond runs a huge international
business and you can see a a Line in the
Sand with how people who don't want to
lose customers talk about all of this
and they have to do it that way and
that's correct but as someone who spends
my time in conservative media with
people people who vehemently disagree
with me I'm I've had it up to here if I
could clutch my pearls any harder you
know whatever it is they try to say that
liberals talk the same way about
conservatives that conservatives talk
about liberals if Donald Trump wins the
presidency again you will have a
president who calls more than half the
country 81 million voted for Joe Biden
74 million for Trump calls us thugs
pedophiles Communists marxists
anti-americans traitors
I I'm not being welcomed into any sort
of I have a question I have a question
for you which I asked Charlamagne
yesterday how many uh
imigrants did Barack Obama Deport in
eight years he's the deporter and Chief
and I
said Milli 2 million he already knows
cuz I told him he hadn't got a scoy
yesterday I thought it was only two it's
over three million it it was the
greatest number Pro rout of any
president in history and it did not hurt
him with latino voters I say it all the
time on the five
Biden can get tougher about this Henry
qu he's got it right how he's talking
about it the Border DS the mark Kelly of
the world that's all fine and good but
to your point about what this world
looked like or this country before covid
Trump setting all these records guess
what Biden's done better than his
records so black unemployment is lower
than it was under Trump Latino
unemployment lower than under let's talk
about oil I can't even tell you how many
times I've been told you know drill baby
drill well Joe Biden's doing it 13.3
million barrels it's the highest amount
of oil produced by any country okay in
history good sales pitch but here's a
critical question for all of you and
it's a one word one word answer if it's
Biden Trump in November who wi no who
wins I I do believe Biden wins
Trump they casting votes by the way
that's why that's what's so scary about
it like you have to think by the way you
don't have to want this to happen but
you're talking about I know but you're
talking about a guy who has 91 criminal
charges a guy who says he wants to be a
dictator for a day a guy who says we
should rip up the Constitution know what
is and that's what I'm saying so if if
Biden has done all of these great things
and he's up against that and we're still
not is he winnable I don't I really
don't know you got to you got to give me
a name who's going to win Biden V Trump
it's not Dean Phillips it's not gonna be
Dean Phillips I really truly don't know
if I had to say right now I would say
Donald Trump wow there we go the casting
vote Charlamagne the god the man with
his finger on the pulse of
America Trump maybe but I I don't know I
really a long that's what's so scary
about it long long time ago brilliant to
have you all thank you very much I'm s
next I'm jumed by the man who asked the
world what is a woman and a lot of
people couldn't answer that's the world
we now live in he's the daily wise Matt
Walsh and he'll be live and un sensor
from New York City
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about to today we do it
all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tor love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on tour TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a living if you're
walking towards me and you're a vegan
you have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegans about
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you this is a
major Summit President Biden decided
this was important after watching a Tom
Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call H terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is talk
TV
welcome back to unsensed live from New
York I'm joined Now by The Daily wise
Matt wsh from Nashville uh how's the
weather Matt I hear it's a little chilly
down there so we got about three inches
of snow and it shut the whole city down
that's the way that's the way we do it
here in the South so uh it's been it's
been an adventure for sure well it's
good to see you um so much to talk about
as always in your wheelhouse but I want
to talk about this extraordinary story
about the Federal Aviation
Administration actively recruiting
workers who suffer severe intellectual
disabilities psychiatric problems and
other mental and physical conditions
under a diversity and inclusion hiring
initiative spelled out on the agency's
website on the face of it this seems
plain ridiculous your
thoughts yeah on the face of it it seems
plain ridiculous I think when you look
deeper it still seems plain ridiculous
now obviously um
no one is claiming that at this point
they're going to hire you know someone
who's blind or paralyzed to actually fly
you know a Delta aircraft 30,000 feet in
the air so we're not maybe we'll get to
that point we're not at that point yet
um but the point is that they have
decided this goes back to I believe it's
2013 an Obama era initiative by the FAA
that they wanted to diversify the
airline industry and uh and they have a
lot of several different groups
that um they wanted to increase their
you know participation in the airline
industry and uh those with disabilities
is one of those groups now what you'll
hear from people on the other side of
this people that are you know fans of
these kinds of diversification efforts
is that well yeah they're doing this but
they're not lowering the standards at
all in order to do it that's the claim
anyway um and and it's true that whether
it's the FAA or any other institution
that is putting d into practice and
trying to diversify uh none of them will
come out and say of course none of them
are going to say that we're lowering the
standards but that obviously is what
ends up happening because if you if you
had the standard set a certain place and
um and then you ended up with like a
certain number of let's say white pilots
and then you say well we don't want that
many white Pilots so we want to get more
of other types of people in there well
what do you have to do with the
standards uh you end up lowering them
and that's exactly exactly what happens
I mean I saw that the the new coach um
in the NFL has replaced bill bich of the
Patriots and he's immediately come out
and played the race card and basically
saying if you don't see color you don't
understand racism and so on uh other
black coaches in the NFL have taken a
very different View and said all they
want to see is football and players they
don't care about what color they are and
it struck me as sort of a bizarre stance
to take because the vast majority of
players for example in the NFL are black
I think nearly
70% what did you make of that when you
heard
it well I think if you are you know that
if we're getting to the point where we
can find anti-black racism in the NFL
well then then just the the concept
means nothing anymore as you point out I
think it's like 70 to 80% of players in
the NFL are black the NFL if you if you
take all the different positions on the
field and on the sidelines it is you
know black
people are vastly over represented when
you compare them to the 133% of the
overall population um so if we're
looking for racism even there then uh
then then it's just the entire concept
is is totally meaningless uh and in
particular this idea that black head
coaches are are being targeted for
racism of course I'm not the first
person to point this out but okay if a
if a lack of NFL of black NFL head
coaches is a result of racism then how
do you explain a lack of say white
defensive backs on the field there's
basically none at this point and are
they being targeted for racism so it
just it just doesn't make any sense yeah
I mean 60% of Americans I think in the
most recent poll I saw are white and yet
they're not represented by 60% white
players in NFL or the NBA or most
American Sports but nobody nobody
complains about that no one says well
hang on that's racist no one would think
that way the other way around and I
admire these uh black coaches in the NFL
whove stood up and went no of course
it's ridiculous it's irrelevant All We
Care is how good the player is or how
good the coach is or how good the
executives
are yeah and that's and and by the way
the reason why people don't complain the
other way is that of course we know that
diversify diversity and inclusion all
these phrases this is coded language and
what it really means is we have to make
these things less white but nobody want
wants to come out and say that that's
one of the reasons why you hear you'll
often hear them refer to um not only
diverse groups but they'll talk about
diverse people we need we need a more
diverse person in this role but how how
can a person individually be diverse
doesn't make any sense well then you
understand what they're really saying is
we want a non-white person they just
don't want to come out and say that I
think another important point that you
brought up is that you know if we are
obsessed with representation if it is
very important that every group be
exactly represented in every industry
that we look at and I don't agree that
that is important I think that's a
that's a an unworkable untenable
unsustainable goal that makes no sense
and it's totally arbitrary but this is
what representation would mean
representation would mean that you have
whatever your percentage is in the
overall population that's what you have
in this industry um but then you find
out that that's not good enough for the
representation police which is which is
interesting right yeah exactly let's
take a short break Matt I want to come
back and talk about the daily wise's
brilliant new comedy movie lady Ballers
which the title may give people a clue
about what issue this is about but of
course it relates to this ongoing furor
around trans athletes in women's sport
we'll talk about that after and show
[Music]
clip we're here thanks for joining yes
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online run your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well Tred most dog owners will tell you
a dog can turn you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she is heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a FSE or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so £40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan should have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans are
out the weirdest plank that we've had in
three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous m
m he should be easy enough to catch this
guy shouldn't he I mean he's got house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
party political broadcast on behal of
the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should aass stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that
welcome back to on sensit from New York
was a lot colder than it looked in that
live shop Matt W is still with me uh
Matt lady Ballers is the brilliant new
movie from you guys at Daily W let's
take a look at a little
clip let's cut to the chase I know
you're not a woman you how he identifies
if you can beat though what do you know
about the US opens for the global games
you want us to compete as women $5,000
prizes my lover says you're were a great
coach back in the day Jo this is the way
the world is now my 8-year-old daughter
told me all about it so a guy can become
a girl with no physical changes at all
oh that's called Jinger
fluid I mean it's a brilliant idea um
first of all why did you make
it well I I can't take credit for making
the movie or writing it or anything like
that I I play a you know relatively
small role in the film and uh I think my
my entire role is really just it's
really just me being trolled by the
director of the film is also CEO of the
company Jeremy boring where he decided
to write a role for me where I am the
exact opposite of who I am in real life
just to make me as uncomfortable as
possible so I'm playing this um this
kind of left-wing hippie character who's
also a big a big hugger you know I'm I'm
big into hugging people in the movie um
but I think the reason why the movie
exists is pretty simple number one it's
a really funny idea and it's also it's
it's it's the kind of it's kind of movie
that needs to exist like this this whole
concept of men competing against women
in women's sports is absurd it's it's
ridiculous it is it's laughable and um
you know if this kind of thing was
happening 25 years ago there would
probably be a comedy like this made
about it but these days well they don't
really make comedies anymore at all but
they certainly aren going to make a
comedy making fun of this so so uh we
did and the truth is that it it really
takes the whole argument on the protrans
aete side to its logical conclusion you
know I've always when I've interviewed
politicians who don't want to uh speak
common sense about this I say well okay
so if you have Limitless self-identity
and anyone can say I'm now female what
happens if Usain Bolt or Floyd
Mayweather decide they want to be a
woman could would you be happier than
competing against biological females in
women's sport and they always have to
say yes and it's always completely
Preposterous Floyd May Mayweather would
kill women in a ring and Usain Bolt
would win the 100 meters women's Olympic
final by about 99 meters I mean it's an
absurdity which this film brilliantly
Lampoons but it's actually
true it is true which is why you don't
have to work that hard to make fun of it
you don't even have to exaggerate that
much uh you know this is one of the
things actually maybe it makes satire
difficult these days is that the reality
itself is so ridiculous that it's
usually in satire you're taking
something uh you're taking the logic to
an extreme extent to show how ridiculous
it is but in this case we you know all
you're doing is this is what's actually
happening in real life and I think that
what you said there there is key though
you said that they that they have to you
we're talking to someone who supports
men and women sports they they they they
have to they have to go along with it
they have to agree to whatever absurd
scenario you throw at them and they
really do they have to um but I don't
think they actually believe it I think
that the number of people who really
deep down believe that it's fair and
right for biological males compete
against females in sports I mean the
number of people is is vanishingly small
but on the left they've basically boxed
themselves into a corner and so they
have to defend this and we should make
them defend it whilst simultaneous
trying to pretend that they are pro
women's rights I mean that's the
absurdity because of course it's women's
rights to fairness and equality that are
being dismantled at this alar of virtue
signaling
nonsense and and there are also the
people that have claimed in the past to
care so much about about maintaining
women's sports that's what Title 9 was
supposed to be about you know I people
often accuse me on the left they'll say
that they'll say well you don't even
care about women's sports that much
you're just pretending I never said that
I I don't I don't wake up at in the
morning uh worrying about women's sports
I don't I don't watch women's sports I I
so in that sense yeah I don't I don't
care about it in that sense but I do
care about just what's right I care
about what's logical what makes sense um
I care about the kids that are involved
in these Sports and protecting them so
uh yeah it but if if you if you do
pretend that this is something that's
very important to you then uh the
question is why why aren't you there
taking up right I mean I care because I
have a 12-year-old daughter who's quite
sporty and I don't want her to if she
was to suddenly be very successful at
some sport in women's sport I don't want
to have her have a dream killed or a
place in a team or you know even you see
it at Olympic level you see women being
deprived of an Olympic place a coveted
glorious Olympic place by a biological
male that it's just not right it's not
fair it's not right it's not equal it's
none of those
things and you're also I I also would
not want my daughter I wouldn't want her
athletic opportunities taken from her if
she decided to get into sports I don't
want her to be in a position where she
has to go along with something that is a
total farce like that it's just it's
wrong to put anybody especially kids the
matter what the context is to put them
in a position where they have to uh
where they feel pressured to go along
with something like that and especially
when the pressure is coming from adults
I mean it's one thing when you deal with
peer pressure as a kid from other kids
but in this case it's the adults that
are using their Authority and their
power to uh Usher you along in this
direction I think it's just utterly
ridiculous now I want to put two
pictures up on the screen for our
audience these are both Calvin Klein uh
underwear uh commercials one Stars a
female model uh and the other one Stars
the Bear's uh actor Jeremy Allen White
and what is comical about this is that
they both reveal a lot of Flesh in fact
the Man reveals more flesh than the
woman the the female one has been
censored by the advertising standard
Authority because it's overtly sexual
but the other one is apparently
absolutely fine I've seen this hypocrisy
a double standard on these kind of
things for decades Matt right it's
absurd isn't
it it is totally absurd I I for for that
one it's hard for me to even understand
I mean usually when you have an
absurdity like this you can understand
what what logic they're going for even
if it doesn't really make sense
ultimately but in that case I'm not even
sure exactly
what what would their argument be
apparently the argument was that the the
ad involving FKA twig the models
physical features rather than the
clothing uh presented as a stereotypical
sexual object he has less clothes on
than she
does yeah it it it doesn't make any
sense but when you're when you're
talking about things like decency and
modesty and and that and that's an
important conversation to have but I
think in our culture we don't have a
very coherent
notion of what that even is or how to
apply it and that's how you end up with
confused situations ridiculous Matt
we've run out of time it's always great
to catch up with you I hope it warms up
down there and I hope to catch up with
you again soon thank you very much
appreciate it thank you that's it for me
whatever you're up to keep it on sent
I'll be back in London next week see you
then good
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
sport today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
on to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dll this one had
booster Rockets attached to it certainly
the tone has shifted in terms of what
Rashi sunak has done the question now is
what he does next the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swear an o in the police to act without
fear or favor the co inquiry seems to
have turned into a sort of pantomime
there's not really any substance to it
it's hard to know whether it's a fce or
a tragedy talk TV has spoken exclusively
to a member of the Blade Runners do you
have a message for sadique Khan we're
not stopping until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the ger cin B Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on his fat ass talking for
liit if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man mcmouse
man mous he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz